brought to you by Assassin's Creed Unity
make history with friends available
November
[Music]
11th it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you follow Hellscream to
the front of the battlefield and
Warlords of dror Hellscream rejects the
demon blood that corrupted and turned
his race green so in this alternate
timeline he molds the orc Clan of old
into the brutal Fighters known as the
iron horde the expansion will allow
players to level up to 100 from the
previous cap of 90 and we'll introduce a
new difficulty of raids called Mythic
Mythic will be the hardest version of
that raid if you think wow is back
you're wrong it never left start rating
November
13th also this week your pirate ship
docks in Paris because it's the French
Revolution and you've got a bunch of
money grubbing powdered wig wearing
people oppressing and Aristocrats to
kill it's Assassin's Creed y'all and
your hidden blade gets an upgrade to
Phantom so you can shoot crossbows from
a distance or get up close and personal
it's your choice this game also offers
Cooperative multiplayer so you can head
to your local Tavern gather up your buds
and go hunting together up to four of
you can hang out in these missions but
there are some missions that are single
player only so you can still kill solo
if you want to start a revolution
November
11th but if you're waiting on Christmas
for Santa to bring you a current gen
console consider Assassin's Creed Rogue
in the mid 18th century during the Seven
Years War you are Shea Patrick karmac an
assassin turned Templar or aslar and you
command his ship Morgan in Black Flag
style gameplay the game introduces an
air rifle which allows the player to
shoot enemies at a distance and you can
adhere firecrackers to it so I would
recommend just doing that for the entire
game become the elusive aslar November
11th also this week you see a darker
side to the Lego world brainia seeks to
command the universe as he shrinks
worlds and keeps them in his pocket
wouldn't it be cool to carry Earth
around in your pocket Lego Batman 3
Beyond Gotham will have over 150
characters from both DC Universe and
returning Batman series and Batman will
need all the help he can get to take
down that mad genius become the Batman
on the
11th so what's in the Halo anniversary
edition actually you got your Halo
Combat Evolved Anniversary
Halo 2 Halo 3 Halo 4 and their
multiplayer modes complete with their
full set of add-on content all games
received graphical upgrades for the
release but Halo 2 received a Halo
Combat Evolved Anniversary style highdef
overhaul from the Geniuses at blur and
holy crap it looks gorgeous relive the
evolution of the master chief November
11th for further details visit
gamespot.com release states are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
[Music]
oh